la france on ne peut plus proche d'un
troisième confinement alors que la
situation sanitaire continue de se
dégrader dans l'hexagone jean castex
prépare déjà le terrain auprès des
parlementaires
à lons du gouvernement le premier
ministre a dévoilé qu'un débat suivi
d'un vote seront organisées à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
si des mesures de confinement sont
adoptées un engagement fort a été pris
par le premier ministre toujours dans la
lignée de ce travail de concertation et
de respect du parlement qui nous anime
depuis le début de cette crise c'est que
si des mesures de confinement devait
être décidée alors elle serait débattue
au parlement qui se prononcera par un
vote sur ces mesures nous avons ensuite
abordé la question de la campagne de
vaccination
ce mercredi le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand a annoncé que les effets
du couvre-feu à 18 heures commençait à
s'estomper et que des mesures
supplémentaires allaient être prises
alors que cette hypothèse se précise
jour après jour la possible remise sous
cloche du pays a déjà suscité bon nombre
de réactions au sein de la classe
politique
quelques heures après la suppression de
la mission parlementaire sur le co vide
la grande trouille des conséquences
dures confinement oblige le gouvernement
à se souvenir de la démocratie
parlementaire
donc jean castex annonce un débat au
parlement sur leur confinement et
maintenant on apprend qu emmanuel macron
pourraient annoncer leur confinement
dimanche soir ils nous prennent
ouvertement pour des imbéciles
on sent une forme de procrastination
c'est à dire qu'on retarde y compris en
instrumentalisant le parlement
de leur côté les français sont ils prêts
à être re confiné selon un sondage au
doxa bakbone consulting pour le figaro
et france info publié ce vendredi
62% des personnes interrogées
soutiennent l'idée d'un troisième
confinement néanmoins c'est un
dispositif dit à la carte qui serait
l'option préférée des français
les restrictions liées au confinement ne
sont-elles accepté que par 14 % de la
population
les fermetures des écoles des bars et
restaurants ou encore des commerces non
essentiels sont aussi largement contesté
par la population d'après ce sondage
si ce nouveau conflit
ensemble de plus en plus probable il
reste désormais à en définir les
modalités
le gouvernement doit trancher entre des
restrictions très serré comme évoqué par
gabriela talent ou des mesures moins
strictes comme en novembre dernier
'l'annonce d'un troisième confinement
pourrait avoir lieu dans les prochains
jours emmanuel macron pourrait
s'adresser aux français ce week-end ou
en début de semaine prochaine